mazie girl can we talk about you
collectively given the Internet a heart
attack right on The Tonight Show gag I
don't know like during shooting like the
final days were really like emotional
saying goodbye to all of the cast
because when I found out that aria died
in like the second episode I was what
how did you come up with that amazing
acting did you rehearse it break it down
for me okay so it was actually like
found him that came up with it it was
the show and then we liked in like a
little warehouse loved it
and then people like wow it's really
convincing good your hands were shaking
your hands for sure yeah it's just live
no we can either that are you serious
yeah dude yeah totally I'm so gonna
tweet about it no it's doing better are
you serious it's fine
I mean I just like full-on have like
really bad anxiety so it just sort of
like I never I always hold my hands like
this or I move them but I never hold
them still because you can see that they
shake so it was just like perfect that I
would hold my hands up and they started
shaking I was like oh girl you're
convincing yourself and then yeah it was
just it was great we do applause and
I'll just go from the positive going
let's talk about let's talk about the
final let's talk about the final season
[Applause]
Giggs put it on his Instagram today ya
know the stove's you Anthony no well
amazing job okay just go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]